You know January twenty ninth. My name is pain and then I'm here with
Joe for I go and where I first ran for the
story project. Library. So if you can
follow what do you remember and.
I remember a lot
of very good memories of hanging out on my
block which was sixty six between twelve and thirteen to have a new hanging out at
the apartment building on the corner right question from Regina apologist grammar school.
It was the Grammar School at the time I attended there were graduated there very warm
memories of. Scuse me hanging out
with my friends and their dad listening to Mecca
games governess to so my friend Donal's father Hank tell me your agenda.
They lost your Jenks go down the block from go down the block and when they were finally
won the championship in eighty six we all celebrated with champagne bottles
a bite at a park. That's a nice memory.
Another nice memory is the guys on my
block or getting together on something mornings we used to go to McKinley High School. McKinley High
School sorry McKinley the schoolyard from the
Kimberley junior high that was located on
seventy third if I'm correct. Right off of what Hamilton and we used to play football there every Sunday
morning use to be about fourteen guys a seven point seven seven polls
first
down her body was the Rajah stop. Ken Stabler or
Drew Peterson and as we've gotten older and talk about those times the plays become
more dramatic The catch is more exciting.
It becomes a little fabricated but those are very nice memories
as well as the Regina you'd sent the original part just as my parish
still lives it to the
silicon now and you have a lot
of C.S.B. a lot of nice memories. Yes of attending
the youth center playing basketball flirting with cheerleaders
bowling being there in one thousand nine hundred seventy three when we were
all bowling and throwing balls of fastly as we could down the lane to sneak into
the bar area and watch the New York Mets against the Cincinnati Reds because it was that the playoffs at that
time were
on in the afternoon and you know
made my confirmation
graduation in that in that
Pacifica a lot of other
nice memories and they put just the sense of community. Everybody had each other's back
and you know it's funny now because now. Now I am fifty two and there are some neighbors that are left on
my
block. You know a lot of people have moved but those that are still on
that block you still have that sense of community and watching each other's.
Back and you know those that use the yell at my brother and I for playing baseball in the
school yard we never really broke maybe want to Windows but you know we were known as the.
But Cassidy and the Sundance kids at the time you know for playing ball which
nowadays pales in comparison to what you do find on Fortunately on
corners and in school yards of what's going on we were kids playing ball or riding up bikes.
You know
all good natured stuff nobody mean but you know. Now you
know when you
when you talk about it with those that are there now respectable guys
we're always we're good guys you know and that whole nature that you always have some bodies.
You always had somebody back. Maybe you didn't totally see eye to eye with a neighbor but God
forbid if any body bothered anybody on that block or something like that
everybody would pitch in in fact my friends and I one night it
was in one thousand nine hundred ninety nine and he was in one thousand nine hundred
one some young girl
got her a pocketbook
Rob and. One of the side entrance of the church my friends and I were like about twelve or
thirteen guys and we helped so we knew every little and we caught the
guy you know we caught him he tried to blend in was really we don't know you and
the cops were there be took away all bad guys we all came out with. You know we were
kids you know we're in our twenty's whatever you know that
but you invaded our block that that wasn't tolerated. If a neighbor.
When we were growing up my friends and I were leaning on somebody's scarf the music was too loud. Somebody
said Guys can you low guys or just clean the car. Yes OK was sorry and that
that sometimes in today's society and of course the Internet
whatever that sense of courtesy and respect but neighbors has gone out the
window but. Those are my words also my really my warmest memories
of Dica hypes been able to go up the fight goes which thank God is still there
on eleventh they haven't you and you know you got when they're on a Saturday you got your
number went to Pete's the hardware store guy a question street the play a lot of that of
yourself go down the can channels not two blocks over get the bread come back you were just in
time fly eagle that was calling your number you got the best call cutting sausages in town and you
went home you made the best
sandwiches and.
Oh what was even like in
the demographic.
Demographics basically a little more Italian oriented at the
time and it is still around but it was at that time it was more
primarily a tongue in oriented oriented
community but that far as the demographics as far as I mean certain Some
businesses have have left the neighborhood of how to close over the years but I think
that would be the biggest the biggest thing the demographic was it was more now it's mix which
is no problem with that on don't take me the wrong way but it was more
primarily an
Italian
based community. Lika
heights. At that particular junction Well when I was growing up.
I was born in this area. Yes I was.
When I was. Like I said fifty
two my first three years I lived on sixty second between
eleven and twelve and then we moved to sixty six between twelfth and thirteenth and that's
where my mom has been living now that's going on fifty years this
year you know so I'm in a neighborhood for a long time. But overall it's good
I mean you know there's Thankfully there's no real
major problems in the area but areas change
as society changes but you
know overall the height of still a very nice place to.
To live in and raise a family.
And you
know over the years well the celebrations that happened over the years.
Regina poshest back in the day when I was a kid I mean I had to be in
and we're between eight to thirteen years old used to have a street there
from sixty fifth and all and thirteen down to seventy fifth and
thirteen as a whole because of all that I remember from my window or from my porch use be
able to see the ferris wheel in the car they'll talk a lot Kabul used to be on sixty
fifth on the corner of sixty fifth and thirteen and that's another nice memory going
there are one night out of the week as they had the Sundays in the helmets so you collected the
baseball home that my brother and I had almost every team of not every team.
I remember as a kid going up to the Fort Wayne movie theater on sixty seventh and
for
Hamilton they used to have what Disney films. One day added week was the summer does mean that and
they you know and these are all very very nice nice
memories as far as what the celebrations. When I used to play baseball for
Regina PA just they used to have like are a sub a Tory mass to begin the baseball season
and I
know a little. Parade around the neighborhood all the stress in our baseball uniforms
all of us future all thought is unthinkable
ballplayers walking around like we're big shots but that's that
was it and now they still have some street there's I mean the eighteenth their new Fiesta
still intact
that tradition for decades I mean that goals that stretches from
sixty fifth and eighteenth of the seventy fifth anything that's been
around for a long long time.
And he visited the library
and I'm always here. I've got to go I'm always stopping in over
here to look up stuff for the print out
front that's just like I come to this library often. Remembering.
Memories is when you have to use that have to do book
reports when you have your projects. Back then going the are circa one nine
hundred seventy S. when I was in grammar school or even in high school in the early
eighty's. You'd have Google then have the Internet where at a touch of a bunch used to
have to go to a library and look up encyclopedias.
You know I know that it looks like something the Antique Roadshow now but you stuff to look up in
and encyclopedias and used to have to research your work
so that's why that's where the
library
became very useful. For
us and my friends and I you know when we had big reports and stuff like that
or things to do per school. You came to the library and that's when you did your
research work if you had to go back in and research things off
of
encyclopedias know not Google not Twitter. The Facebook. No.
None of
that you know you just have to go to a library and read through
your stuff and make copies or write down your
notes. Oh oh.
As you live in this is the library.
Is one of the banking system
and you know it was it was a central player because if you did have
a lot of studying to do for a fine old or any type
of examinations you know sometimes the four walls of your house gets a little close then
you know you will take a little
walk get a little fresh air clear your head come to the library was quiet and do
you studying and do you know what do some
homework as far as that goes what he needed and you want to take out a book
that you were looking to they wanted to read especially
when you're when you're young and older before the Barnes and Noble's and everything.
Became a major player. This is this was the source that you came to you came to your local library.
And
the friends or
family. Know none of us all legends in our
own mind. Like I say school
your school your memories that become for blog now when you when you
talk with your friends we've had some reunions and you know of course the stories come up when we play football
and you know who did this catch was and you know everything is fabricated is it's all a lot
of a lot of good fun. You know to reminisce.
Because like I said you had a lot of good a lot of good memories and all of us.
Thankfully we had very good. You know good families and stuff
unfortunately some of us including ourselves myself have lost family members like fathers
and uncles over the years and when you do
go through things like that as you get older and
you do look back on on things those memories become even more in the
airing and you realize really how lucky. Excuse me I'm blessed that you
were and that you are.
You know lucky hang out locations for me as a. Kid growing up.
It was up on the corner like I said buddy apartment building listen in the mechanisms down
on sixty six then eleven.
As far as going out when I was you know
when you hit that age where you're able to go out to the blogs and stuff it would be Third Avenue. But there are
avenues more pay Ridge. Harriet's not really to dot the Heights area. So as
far as hanging out and like a height. It would be the schoolyards
playing. Playing automatics in this we are sixty ninth and.
And twelfth fifth was an automatic homerun if not the fourth was a homer of course
it was an out things like that playing football and they're playing what a matic
softball
fastball in the in the attic which is the school yard that's located on the corner off the corner of
sixty four and and twelve the avenue or as a
kid growing up you know before you were really old enough
to branch out and leave your block read questions Fritzi in a pub just who you are. Were football that was our
Shea Stadium Yankee Stadium. I was but Haralson who
was Larry ball you know and you want to talk about graffiti OK was graffiti but we used
to write on the school yard fence. So we used
the box scores of of our games and
and stuff playing basketball off of
the. The garbage pails that they put in the point of these large containers so
we had
to
roll the regular like garbage pails and we
used to shoot hoops and stuff like that playing the skulls in the street and
my neighbor I was a bottle caps and used to melt the. The crayon to get the
cap a better
Smoove right when you hit when you were hitting it again playing slap
ball playing hockey in the schoolyard reaching apologise across the
street from a used to ice the puck. You used to get the rolls of the black electric tape
to keep him in the freezer that's where his ace lives better. On the contrary. And
unfortunately you don't see that anymore. And that's a
little bit of a problem and
that's why these kids aren't as active as they should be and that's why obesity I think with
with children is up and I come to a library like I do
today and the kids are wrong the things and all the doing is playing computer games.
It's a beautiful day it's a Friday afternoon you don't have any school.
It's a long weekend get out there play some football play some basketball be more active
but like I said those those things that at that was my childhood I wanted whatever the season
was we had something going on bowling basketball or
football we there was the the light on the corner if there was enough light got the ball
smacked around whatever that's that's what we
did and no those were my hang out and. In Dhaka heights I mean
the park wait diner on seventy fifth and thirteenth always very very
good always got a good lunch or breakfast and then they had a
pizzeria Lawson retainer up on sixty six and eleven Thank God they're still
around nicest guys you would ever want to encounter excellent food like I said by eco
great bunch of guys Young's Deli on sixty eight
thousand and eleven. These were my hangouts this is my this is my neighborhood.
You
know I think any of this no one and no.
No that basically it and then the other thing that let me add to is my block we're
fortunate we had block parties and I was ten years old and we had our first one in one
thousand nine hundred seventy three and not a day
either but we had block parties it was a big thrill you were able to ride your bike in
the street and you know and then we had one of seventy four that it stopped and we
got a new bunch of young. Neighbors that moved in and then we had one in eighty six
and eighty
seven and by that time now in my twenty's and so my friends of course were at all
block this is all block that was the over that was the block playing you
know. Having a block party. Having your friends over
or you know enjoying like your mom's cooking and they would bring over
food we would be playing in the street different that different games.
We played. Would we play. Oh musical
chairs where the guys would sit on a chair and a woman would walk around my
friend Dino for me at it again if they like the second or third times I was flirting with his wife
you know a good natured flirting of course but I'm just saying he's like I said as you get
older in
life and you get to look back you realize how looking at bless your work is not a
lot of people have those type of really nice memories of their
childhood or their or the neighborhood and I'm very
blessed that I
do I really am I mean my aunts the four blocks away to
my sixty second allotment and you know my aunt to my uncle's unfortunate my uncles are passed by
my aunts God bless them eighty five and eighty eight are still
there and I you know that that that place that at that a second home. That's where
I grew up playing ball again because I had growing up I had guys we were all
the same age and we all became friends and stuff
like I said I have very very very blessed that I have very very good memories of
my
childhood my neighborhood that I grew up with and
family and not a lot of people have
that unfortunately.
Value play the lottery that says
oh yeah golf I never got into golf and tennis. I wasn't didn't have a good hand eye
coordination my younger brother was a very good tennis player. I never had that hand eye
coordination for for tennis
and golf one of the guys really we were football basketball
hockey baseball mainly baseball and football and I enjoyed
the bowling Rejean apologist when the Regina youths out there was very
active downstairs they had lanes. They had bowling lanes.
And when I was in Regina poshest grammar school they had leaks. For the kids
different ages and I belong there fact my mom volunteered she was a score keeper when I was
younger and then as I got older my cousin and
a couple of his
friends we were a forman they had the form in leagues and
my father got us to so many times over he belonged to the league to the mentally. So
I guess it was a very very active neighborhood especially what
was going on that.
Regina with the church and the school junior partner school
went there. You
know graduated there in seventy seven. So like I said this was a
very it was a very active nice nice
time you need really nice pubs and I
know everything was in walking distance just the only time that we my friends and I would take public
transportation was out when we travelled into the Bay Ridge but that wasn't until we were
older and tell you to and it seems everything that we basically did was
really within a mile the two mile area walking distance
of where we were born and raised.
Oh well let me begin life. My.
Family is the center of everything you have a good thing Amalie kids today I've got a
nice That is for God bless and nephew that is seven
and you want to enrich them with family. They know that their
love they enjoy their own tools they enjoy their families your
families really the center of everything and the other thing that I learned to is
that good friendships I mean really good true
friendships something that you know it sounds cliche but it. They are
priceless
and the other thing that you learn too as you get older in life is that not everybody
has what you may have been lost.
And embrace it. Enjoy it. Appreciate
it because it's not it's it's not always and
hasn't always been there for people you learn just as you get older and you know
you go out to high school and college and you get to know more people and you hear about their backgrounds and
their families what their fault is
especially their you don't always have what
you
had and how sometimes you know it's
the it's easier said than done but sometimes when you're in the middle of it you don't realize
that sometimes you do you can't take for granted thing is that everybody's got this. But
again I can't repeat it enough as you get older and you stop branching out into life.
You realize that not everybody did and that's when you take
a step back and say you know what Dan
it really lucky I've been really blessed and I can I know I've been saying that a
lot but it's the truth and that's really what the Heights has
been all about. I may have been very blessed to grow up in this area
with the friends that I've had over the years childhood friends even if we don't stay in contact with each other
anymore people and life's and moved on
but there's always be that sense of neighborhood. Whenever you run into those
guys or those people. They want to talk about.
I think we covered
about about everything. Like I said I
mean it was it was a great time growing up
in and like a high. I mean you know. Guys the guys
and kids are kids and listen you got picked on you got
bullied. A little bit
but you know what if you got bullied and you got picked on. You always had a family to fall back on and that's what
I honestly came on the stand with with today when these kids are and I understand that that high school is
rough and I. Then the S.P.L. pressure. It's always been around. It's always
been around. Well back when your
family half if things are getting getting too hard.
As far as that goes.
And that's one thing that I didn't learn because I did I got back up bullied a little bit in high school I
got picked on because I had the glasses when I went to high and went with the car high school and when
I went
to to grammar school when you got called names. I hate to say
but that's a normal course of growing up and unfortunately
think in today's society. Everything just gets too overanalyzed and you know
what it all comes down
to what goes on within the four walls of
home of home at dinner table not a
nice memory. Don't touch upon dinner table my father was always home for
dinner and it was always important that we talk.
How did they go. How school.
What's going on in your life.
OK I
think I have and I know society has changed a lot
and with the economics of it all of that but take.
Take the
time take the time to sit and talk with the kids talk with your
wife talk with your husband communicate. OK
what's on T.V. or stay on T.V. You can D.V.R. whatever you can do now. OK.
The main thing is communicating and I love to get this one of my math
teachers in Bishop for because I was whole trouble with math of never my my best subject in high
school and I went for tutoring and they went up for an open
house and he complimented my parents pushed me taking an active role in your
kids and your children's life and that's the key there for get
my for my legacy my father unfortunately is passed it's going to be twenty four years this February twentieth.
They passed away on his fifty four.
But. Anyway.
My mother always played the heavy. I mean we knew what we could do what we couldn't do with my dad only. He was no pushover.
But my mother told us after repair to go who always thought that I was playing what having that your father was a little
more passive a little more laid back. She was let me tell
you once you used his car and you pulled away and you away for about fifteen twenty minutes
or your friend pick you up and you guys were going off and I thought he would wait about twenty minutes or
so he would go through the draws he think if he found a
Playboy magazine in mind if he found an X. rated tape you know if we were killed. We were
guys you're going to try to hide that from your parents although they knew you were doing it anyway
but that's again that's a normal thing a ritual of growing up and the main thing is you want to
make sure he wasn't finding
drugs and if he did he would have addressed.
Nowadays we live in society where that could be a voice.
It's called parenting. It's called staying in touch and and unfortunately
today we have to have commercials that are trying to teach people to do
that where they. You know that's what they did at
that house that was what was done and you know my brother my younger brother is forty nine
and he's got two kids like I said my niece that is four and my nephew that seven every night
they have dinner at the table. They
talk nice and mine and my nephew we provide them with
a lot of love you know we spoil them a little bit within reason you know with the purpose being an uncle I get
to give them back but that's the whole key sense of family and that's really I think the
biggest thing that I learned as a good
family. It's like working out your body you need that solid core and then
all the other muscle groups and everything fall into place and you have a very good core family.
Everything else in life really just falls into place.
Right well.
Thank you for your time.